>> THESE MASSIVE FLOWS PLACE A
MASS BURDEN ON OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
DOING A GLOBAL PANDEMIC, THEY
THREATEN TO CREATE A PERFECT
STORM THAT WOULD SPREAD THE
INFECTION TO OUR BORDER AGENTS,
MIGRANTS AND THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE.
THIS WOULD CRIPPLE OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, OVERWHELM
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND
SEVERELY DAMAGE OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO LET THAT
HAPPEN.
>> Laura: YES!
PRESIDENT TRUMP CLOSING THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER TO FIGHT
CORONAVIRUS.
REMEMBER WHEN PEOPLE SAID YOU
COULDN’T CLOSE THE BORDER?
I GUESS THEY WERE WRONG.
ALLOWING ESSENTIAL TRAVEL AND
TRADE.
WE WARNED YOU ABOUT A POTENTIAL
NIGHTMARE UNFOLDING AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
LAST WEEK, THE NUMBER OF
CONFIRMED CASES QUADRUPLED FROM
40 TO MORE THAN 160.
THAT IS ONLY WHAT THE OFFICIAL
STATS TELL US.
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT DOESN’T
SEEM TO CARE AT ALL.
WHY THEY DID CLOSE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS, THERE’S NO TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS AND LIMITED
SCREENINGS OF ANY TRAVELERS.
LARGE GATHERINGS, CONCERTS AND
STUFF ARE STILL HAPPENING.
WHAT YOU HAVE HERE ARE THE
INGREDIENTS EPIDEMIOLOGISTS ARE
SAYING FOR AN EPIC DISASTER.
HERE’S HOW ONE OF MEXICO’S TOP
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS PUT IT.
WE HAVE ALL THE CONDITIONS TO
TURN THIS INTO A TRAGEDY SIMILAR
TO ITALY.
IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
MEXICO OVERTOOK ITALY?
CHAD WOLF PAINTED A DIRE PICTURE
EARLIER TODAY.
>> THE OUTBREAK ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER WOULD INCREASE THE STRAIN
ON HEALTH SYSTEMS IN OUR BORDER
COMMUNITIES.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW, ACTING
CBP COMMISSIONER MARK MORGAN.
THE BORDER IS CLOSING.
DOES THAT MEAN ENFORCEMENT IS
ENHANCED AND MORE BOOTS ARE ON
THE GROUND?
HOW ARE WE "CLOSING THE BORDER."
IN PLACES WHERE I WAS, IT WAS
DESOLATE.
>> SO ALL OF THAT HAS HAPPENED.
BUT WORDS MATTER.
IT MEANS SOMETHING DIFFERENT TO
CERTAIN PEOPLE.
WE’RE NOT REALLY CLOSING THE
BORDER.
AS YOU SAID IN YOUR OPENING,
WE’RE ABSOLUTELY LIMITING AND
TAKING REASONABLE RESTRICTIONS
TO CONTAIN AND MITIGATE.
BUT STILL OPEN TO ESSENTIAL
TRAVEL AND A CARGO COMMERCIAL
TRADE WILL CONTINUE TO FLOW.
BUT THIS PRESIDENT, THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THIS HAS EVER
HAPPENED THAT WE’VE TAKEN THESE
AUTHORITIES AND APPLY THEM.
WE’RE DOING IT AT THE NORTHERN
BORDER AND THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
AGAIN, THIS IS BOLD, AGGRESSIVE
ACTION.
BUT IT’S YET COMMON SENSE AND
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
>> Laura: MARK, WE’VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS BEFORE.
WE’RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
NORMAL ENTRY POINTS WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE TO MEET A BORDER PATROL
OFFICIAL, A CUSTOMS OFFICIAL.
WE’RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
JUST WALK ACROSS THE BORDER A
LITTLE FENCE WHERE WE DON’T HAVE
THE WALL YET OR PEOPLE THAT
FLOAT ACROSS THE RIO GRANDE.
PEOPLE WERE FLOATING THE
RIO GRANDE LAST YEAR AND IT WAS
NARROW IN THE PLACES WE WERE AND
SHALLOW IN SOME PLACES BUT STILL
WATER MOVES.
THEY WERE JUST TURNING
THEMSELVES IN TO BORDER PATROL
AND THEN GETTING BUSSED TO A
DIFFERENT PART OF TEXAS AND
ULTIMATELY RELEASED INTO THE
COUNTRY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT WE’VE ALSO
GOTTEN RID OF OR SUSPENDED ALL
ASYLUM APPLICATIONS AT PORTS OF
ENTRY.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> YOU’RE RIGHT.
THAT’S A GAME CHANGER.
THAT’S THE BOLD AGGRESSIVE
ACTION THAT THIS PRESIDENT TOOK
TODAY.
WITH THE CDC ORDER WHAT THEY
HAVE SAID IS THAT EXACTLY WHAT
YOU’VE BEEN SAYING, LAURA.
WE’VE BEEN PART OF THE TASK
FORCE FROM DAY ONE AND WE’VE
BEEN TALKING WITH CDC AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
THEY GAVE THE FINAL ORDER THAT
ALLOWS CBP TO DO WHAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED.
WHEN THEY ENTER ILLEGALLY, THEY
HAVE NO DOCUMENTATION.
INSTEAD OF TAKING THEM IN --
>> Laura: I’M SAYING, WE COULD
HAVE DONE THIS -- WE SHOULD
NEVER HAVE TAKEN THEM IN.
THIS IS WHAT WE SAW WHEN WE WERE
THERE.
I WANT TO REMIND YOU, THESE
FAMILY UNITS CAN COME BY THE
THOUSANDS IN THE UNITED STATES,
CROSSING THE RIO GRANDE AND
BEING RELEASED IS BECAUSE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS SUED,
LIBERAL JUDGES PUT AN INJUNCTION
STOPPING THE ADMINISTRATION FROM
SENDING PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY BACK.
CORRECT?
THAT WAS LIBERAL JUDGES WHO AT
THE TIME WERE ENDANGERING OUR
HEALTH, SECURITY AND JUST OUR
SCHOOL RESOURCES AND EVERYTHING
ELSE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS TRIED TO DO
BEFORE AND JUDGES STOPPED THEM.
NOW EVERYONE IS A BORDER HAWK
BECAUSE THEY’RE LIKE WELL, MY
LIFE MIGHT BE IN JEOPARDY NOW.
>> WELL, LAURA, YOU’RE SPOT ON.
THIS IS ANOTHER -- TODAY RIGHT
NOW, THIS IS NOT ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IS BORDERS
MATTER THOUGH.
THAT’S WHAT WE’RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW.
THE UNPRECEDENTED BOLD ACTION
THIS PRESIDENT IS TAKEN IS FIRST
AND FOREMOST.
IT’S A HEALTHCARE CRISIS.
WE NEED TO PROTECT -- FOR ME, I
WANT TO PROTECT THE MEN AND THE
WOMEN OF THE CBP AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WITH THIS BOLD ACTION, THE
IMMIGRANTS WILL BE PROTECTED AS
WELL.
SO ONCE THEY COME ACROSS
ILLEGALLY, THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE CBP, WE’RE TURNING AROUND
RIGHT THERE AROUND RETURNING
THEM TO MEXICO.
>> YOU LIKE THE WORLD "BOLD"
MARK.
YOU SAID VERY BOLD.
IT IS BOLD.
IT WAS BOLD LAST YEAR WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION DID THIS.
THEY TRIED TO STOP THIS NONSENSE
A YEAR AGO.
AGAIN, TRUMP WAS WAY AHEAD OF
THE CURVE ON THIS BORDER
PROBLEM.
NOW ALL OF THESE OTHER PEOPLE
ARE COMING ALONG TO THE VIEW.
HOWEVER, COMMISSIONER MORGAN,
JOE BIDEN JUST EIGHT DAYS AGO
WAS TWEETING THIS.
HE SAID, A WALL WILL NOT STOP
THE CORONAVIRUS.
BANNING ALL TRAVEL FROM EUROPE
OR ANY PART OF THE WORLD WILL
NOT STOP IT.
THIS DISEASE WILL NOT STOP.
WE NEED A PLAN TO COMBAT IT.
JOE BIDEN WOULDN’T HAVE DONE
THIS.
WE WOULD HAVE MORE PEOPLE
FLOODING IN FROM AFFECTED AREAS.
>> NINE MONTHS, 30 DAYS, BECAUSE
OF THE TACTICS THAT WE’VE TAKEN
OWN I’LL SAY IT BECAUSE OF THE
BOLD ACTION --
>> Laura: A DRINKING GAME HERE.
>> IN A SINGLE MONTH, WE’VE
REDUCED THAT FLOW BY 100,000.
THAT’S -- RIGHT NOW, IN THIS
PANDEMIC THAT WE’RE IN, THAT’S
100,000 LESS INDIVIDUALS THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ILLEGALLY
ENTERING OUR COUNTRY.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY A GAME
CHANGER.
AND THE WALL IS A PART OF THAT.
>> Laura: WE NEED ALL OF THAT.
THIS HAS TO BE A LESSON FOR
GOING FORWARD.
WE DON’T NEED T.B. COMING INTO
OUR COUNTRY, OUR SCHOOLS.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
WE DON’T NEED NEW WORKERS.
WE NEED PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AS
SOON AS MEDICALLY POSSIBLE AND
OKAY HEALTH-WISE.
COMMISSIONER MORGAN, GREAT TO
SEE YOU.
STAY SAFE OUT THERE AND OUR LOVE
TO THE BORDER PATROL.
THEY’RE AMAZING PEOPLE.